♪ ♪
>> Greg: THE WHITE HOUSE
SPINNING FASTER THAN GUIDANCE
PELOTON AFTER BEING FORCED TO
NEGOTIATE WITH TALIBAN
TERRORISTS.
TODAY AFTER BIDEN STRANDED THEM
THERE, THE PENTAGON CALLING THE
TERRORISTS BUSINESSLIKE WHILE
AMERICANS ARE STILL STUCK THERE
IN JEN PSAKI TRYING TO CLAIM IT
WAS THE PLAN ALL ALONG.
>> YOU SAID THE TALIBAN IS
BUSINESSLIKE AND PROFESSIONAL.
THEIR INTERIOR MINISTER IS ON
THE FA WANTED POSTER.
WHAT IS THE BUSINESS?
>> WE ARE HERE TO CELEBRATE THE
RETURN OF AMERICAN CITIZENS WHO
WANTED TO LEAVE AFGHANISTAN,
LEGAL PERMANENT RESIDENTS,
AFGHANS WHO FOUGHT BY OUR SIDE
ON QATAR AIRLINES FLIGHT.
WE HAD TO WORK WITH SOME MEMBERS
OF THE TALIBAN TO PRESS THEM AND
WORK IN A BUSINESSLIKE MANNER TO
GET THEM OUT.
THAT'S WHAT WE WERE STATING.
>> IT SAYS "THIS IS A POSITIVE
FIRST STEP."
TOWARDS WHAT?
>> TOWARDS GETTING ADDITIONAL
PEOPLE OUT DO WANT TO LEAVE
AFGHANISTAN.
>> Greg: JUDGE, THE PREVIOUS
SEGMENT EXPLAINS EVERY TIME YOU
APPROACH THE ISSUE OF
AFGHANISTAN, YOU SEE THE
INCOMPETENTS.
YOU SEE THE HORRIBLE
IMPLEMENTATION.
THE WORST FOREIGN POLICY YOU'VE
SEEN IN YOUR RECENT LIFETIME.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE THE A BLOCK.
>> Judge Jeanine: THAT'S
RIGHT.
THE BEST PART OF THIS IS THEY
ARE SAYING WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
THE SIX CHARTER PLANES STUCK IN
THE NORTHERN PART OF THE
COUNTRY.
THEY SAY WE COULDN'T GET THOSE
PLANES OUT BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
PEOPLE ON THE GROUND.
WHY DON'T WE HAVE PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND?
WE DON'T HAVE PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND BECAUSE WE HAD ALL THE
MI